[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello, and welcome
to episode number 67 of the
weekly daily Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
It is day three here
at Google Cloud Next.
I am Francesc Campoy
and, as always, I'm
here with my
colleague, with my dear
colleague, today, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
It's my birthday.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh!
That's awful.
I said I was going to
say it before he said it.
Happy birthday, Mike,
from me and all the people
that we interviewed.
And there's actually a lot
of people that came just
to say happy birthday.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And I'm going to say
that if you're listening
to this episode,
you should definitely
tweet at @Neurotic and say,
happy birthday, Neurotic.
MARK MANDEL: Aw.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He
appreciates dogs.
So you can take pictures of
cute dogs and he'll be happy.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, I will.
That's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
Today we are very lucky
to get to interview
three amazing people
from Google Cloud.
Two of them working
for marketing,
that's the first interview
we're going to have.
And we're going to be talking
about something pretty amazing.
If you have watched
the keynote, you
may have noticed
that Urs was wearing
some really cool earring.
MARK MANDEL: So at least we
know that he is always Urs
because he has the chip,
he is the real Urs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
We're going to learn what that
chip, what that earring is,
and what the backstory
behind it is.
It is a very interesting one.
And after that, we'll be
talking to Miles Ward, who
is an all-around great guy.
He's been doing cloud
stuff for a very long time.
And I'm just excited to talk
to him, no matter the topic.
MARK MANDEL: Miles is fantastic.
He's the Global Head of
Solutions at Google Cloud
and always has fantastic stories
about customers and engagements
that he's had
across the platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we get to
talk to Miles Ward later on.
But for now, let's go talk about
Urs's earring, with our friends
from marketing.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Let's do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're now joined
by two very, very important
people here at Cloud Next.
MARK MANDEL: Very important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
have Cornelius Willis
and Neal Mueller.
How are you both doing?
NEAL MUELLER: Awesome.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
We're great, now
that I know how important I am.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So for everybody
else that does not know
how important you are,
why don't you tell us a
little bit of who you are
and what do you do at Google?
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
I'm Cornelius Willis,
and I take care of
product marketing
for Google Cloud
Platform, which means
I get to work with
amazing people like Neal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What about you, Neal?
NEAL MUELLER: My
name's Neal and I
work on infrastructure product
marketing at GCP, which means
I get to work with Cornelius.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we have you here
specifically for something that
happened during the keynote.
NEAL MUELLER: The chip.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, the
chip, which was pretty amazing.
If you're listening
to the podcast
and you have not
seen the keynote,
I recommend go and watch it.
At some point, Urs--
I'm going to try
to say his name.
I think it's always a test.
Urs Holzle?
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Urs Holzle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Holzle.
I'm going to go
with Urs for now.
So Urs showed that he was
wearing an earring that
was a chip that does
authentication for stuff
and machines in the cloud.
What is that thing?
CORNELIUS WILLIS: That is
the Titan authentication
chip that goes on a whole
bunch of Google hardware.
Essentially, every
piece of hardware
in Google's infrastructure
can be individually identified
in any service using it,
mutually authenticates
to that hardware.
And the Titan chip is one of
the ways we accomplish that.
We were so excited to be
able to actually reveal that.
If we think about product
marketing's job for Google
Cloud Platform, it's
to convince leadership
to progressively expose more
and more Google innovation,
even if we're a little
uncomfortable with it.
So this is a great example
of when we were actually
able to throw back the
kimono on something that
is really interesting and is
really different from what
other cloud platforms provide.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I like the joke that
Urs did which was,
since we have the Titan chip,
this is an authentic Google
Cloud Platform.
Like, at Google Cloud
Platform keynote
we know for sure that it's him.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
And the thing, too,
is I was a little worried when
he removed it from his ear,
because then he was no longer
in a trusted good state
and we might have
had to shut him down.
So it would've
happened to a process.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
could've been compromised.
MARK MANDEL: You need
to get a new one.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
And done, right?
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, it
has been deactivated.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Well, because
everything in the environment
is untrusted until
proven trusted.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
talk about the chip.
What exactly does the chip do?
NEAL MUELLER: Let's
take a step back.
Before we start getting into
the nerdery of this security
microprocessor.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
just very excited.
MARK MANDEL: I'm just
really excited by the nerdy.
NEAL MUELLER: Let's
tell an analogy.
I bet there's more people
in the audience that
have seen the movie "Inception"
than understand what a security
microprocessor is,
which is what Titan is.
So if you've seen the
movie "Inception"--
MARK MANDEL: And if you have
not, you should go see it.
Incredible movie about--
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
You kind of have
to see that in order to--
if you haven't seen it,
you've got to stop
listening to the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'd say so, yeah.
NEAL MUELLER: So
"Inception" is all
about this thing in philosophy
called simulation theory.
And it's the disconnection and
the concern about there being
a disconnection between
your perception of reality
and reality itself, that you
might actually be living inside
of somebody else's dreams,
somebody else's Sim City,
and it's not actually
your own little life.
That's exactly the
concern that Google
has with regard to our
hardware and our software.
We want to make sure
that the relationship
between our hardware and our
software comes up in a way
that we consider trusted.
And that's why we have a
security microprocessor
that we called Titan
that authenticates
this relationship.
Every time we push
a new piece of BIOS,
which is software
located on the hardware,
Titan authenticates
that installation.
And every single time that
hardware boots up some software
that we've given it, it
authenticates that boot-up.
And it allows us to have,
like Cornelius said,
authenticated
service-to-service-level
communication between our
hardware and our software,
and also between our
software in our software.
It's really similar
in theory to the stuff
that we also have
in our security
keys that every Googler
has on their computer.
Insofar as we believe at
Google that everything
should have an identity.
Our hardware has identity,
our software has identity.
We live in a constant state that
we consider always untrusted
and we verify the identity of
everything all of the time.
And that way, if anything in our
infrastructure is deemed rogue,
we can very quickly de-identify
it and then carry on
with business.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
wondering, does that
mean that every single
one of those little chips
has some secret
built-in in there,
like [? YubiKey, ?]
something that at any point
you can decide which one is
the one that is not a good one
and you just stop
trusting the machine
or whatever piece of
hardware you have?
NEAL MUELLER: Yes, so how do
you know that the type itself
is the real type?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
because you have many of them.
So where did you start--
MARK MANDEL: Let's go deeper.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's turtles,
all the way down, let's.
NEAL MUELLER: We fuse
each individual Titan chip
with a unique identifier.
And this doesn't
mean the writing
that was on the top, although
we did remove that when
we gave it to Urs and let him
make an earring out of it.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: It wasn't
good on the jewelery, anyway.
NEAL MUELLER: No,
it's not out of style.
It's gauche.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
We were competing
with the diamond stud.
So we had the
little numbers now.
NEAL MUELLER: The fusing happens
inside the read-only memory
of the chip itself.
And it's done
sequentially so that we
can tell that it's a Titan
chip that's in our inventory
sequence and
theoretically is only
being able to be
written once and can't
be changed within the
chip during the chip's
entire lifetime.
So you know that that
is the real McCoy.
MARK MANDEL: And
just to be clear,
we make the chips, right?
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Yeah.
A lot of our stuff,
we control the design
and the manufacturer.
That's so we are able to ensure
to the greatest degree possible
it has not been tampered with.
NEAL MUELLER: This is one
of the big differentiators
of our cloud versus
every other cloud
that I've been able to
learn anything about.
There are other folks that run
data centers, and other clouds
as well, and they
can buy servers
that have security
microprocessors on them.
The majority of those
that I've talked to
don't use those security
microprocessors.
In fact, no cloud that
I've been able to talk to
uses their security
microprocessors
that are given to
them by other vendors.
Not only do we use those,
but we created our own,
because it's not our jam to
not understand fully the supply
chain.
So we purpose-build our
servers, and our chips,
and our security
microprocessors, and our racks,
and our network controllers,
as you saw in the picture
when Urs was up on stage.
We want to fully
understand the supply chain
so that we can
guarantee provenance
over the security of our cloud.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
It's not just identity
that we're trying
to authenticate,
but also heritage.
Where did that thing come from?
Provenance.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it sounds
like it's the whole thing too,
from BIOS all the way
through to software.
Is it doing the thing we
think it's meant to be doing?
And if it's not--
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
And perpetually
challenge that across
the entire system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So to
go back a little bit
and get a little bit away
from the geekness area,
we will be back
there in a minute.
MARK MANDEL: Eh.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Who
had the idea of saying,
oh, let's put a
chip on Urs's Ear
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Urs
saw the little chip.
Neal, first of all,
somehow convinced someone
to give him some of these chips.
Neal is a very robust
guy, so I don't know
what happened to that person.
But we got the chips.
So Neil showed them
to Urs and they're
these very cute little things.
And Urs said, ooh, that
could be an earring.
And then he looked at me a few
minutes later and said, no.
No, don't do that.
MARK MANDEL: He knew
where it was going.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: And Neal
in the meantime had gone off
and found--
I don't know where
you found earrings.
NEAL MUELLER: One of
our product managers,
Maya, knew of a
craft store nearby
and I hustled over there.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
you got both the earring
posts and the superglue
at the same store.
NEAL MUELLER: Same place, yeah.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very useful.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Very efficient.
So he came back with the
studs and convinced him
that it would be something
that would really get
his picture in a lot of places.
NEAL MUELLER: And could
potentially glue his ear
together with superglue.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Yeah.
And the thing that I think
we were excited about
is figuring out how to
actually map this down
into Urs's own sort
of immune system.
So it's just the same way
we have an immune system
for our cloud, maybe
we could figure out
how to make that connection.
MARK MANDEL: I'm a
little sad, actually.
I tried to put it
through my ear.
I had my ear pierced
when I was like 15 or so,
and the hole slightly closed.
So I couldn't put it in
properly and then I was like--
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Well, maybe it's
because you're not
authenticatable.
MARK MANDEL: No!
No, no.
You know what?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Maybe
you need to press harder.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I'm
not Urs and it's going,
well, I don't know who you are,
so we're not doing this thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Going back to
the geekness area, I'm curious.
So this is a very
useful thing to have.
The fact that you're
able to authenticate
a piece of hardware, it
is amazing for us, Google.
But it might also be amazing
for other people, everyone
in the world.
Is this something that
is offered as a service?
Or it's just like
a security layer
that is internal to Google?
NEAL MUELLER: Right now
we're the only cloud
that we know of that's
currently using a security
microprocessor.
Not only are we the only
one using one, period,
but we're the only one
that has purpose built one.
If we were to make this chip
addressable for customers,
configurable for customers,
we would be the first cloud
to do so.
We don't currently do that.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
That's fair enough.
I think this is also
very interesting,
the whole question of
the cloud, and this often
comes up where it's like,
hey, is the cloud secure?
And then we get that sort
of thing like, oh, god,
we can't move
things to the cloud.
NEAL MUELLER: This is one
of those great examples
of, oh, my gosh--
what did Eric
Schmidt say on stage?
He was like, [INAUDIBLE]
the cloud now.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: And don't
try to do this yourself,
it's a waste of your money.
MARK MANDEL: But it seems like
this is the sort of thing where
you're like, is this the type of
security you would do yourself
if you're building
stuff on your own,
like data centers or networks?
How much effort do you
want to put in yourself?
It must have been a huge
investment to make this--
CORNELIUS WILLIS: And
a huge investment,
not only in money, but in time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, research.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Many, many, many years
of building out the
layered architecture.
And then it hasn't stopped.
NEAL MUELLER: You
might be curious
what goes into a security
microprocessor like Titan.
So within Titan
are three things--
a random number generator,
a crypto engine,
and a monotonic counter.
So of those three,
the one that I really
didn't understand until I
googled it was monotonic
counter.
And now that I
learned what it means,
I'm super excited to share.
A monotonic counter
is essentially
something that protects
against replay attacks,
in addition to other
threat vectors.
And it ensures that a count
goes forward and never backward.
It's a tool within logs
to make tamper evident.
Because if you were ever to
remove a log and say, oops,
that never happened, that
person never came here,
it would be obvious
because it would
go from two to four to five.
It'd be obvious that
you removed something.
And if you tried
to insert something
and say something happened
when it actually didn't, the
monotonic counter
would be proof positive
that it had not occurred.
Those are the three things
inside a secure microprocessor.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we said what goes
inside of Titan, talked
about what it's used for.
Where does it actually
go other than on ears?
NEAL MUELLER: Yeah, sure.
So the position
is very important
for this particular product.
It needs to sit
between ROM and RAM
in order to provide a signature
validation of the first eight
kilobits of installation
of a BIOS, for example,
or the boot-up of any of
our pieces of hardware.
And once it validates
the first eight kilobytes
of installation, it lets you
install the rest of the BIOS
and in every machine boot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So one last question.
Is this something
we're going to start
creating a fashion line on it?
Are people starting to use it?
Do you see people in
Mountain View walking around
with chips on their heads?
Which would not surprise
me, to be honest.
NEAL MUELLER: No.
Yeah, we're going
to be making these.
The Titan chip is
comprised of an outer case
and an inner microprocessor.
We're removing the
inner microprocessor
and then we're going to
be attaching the exterior
cake to cuff links,
earrings, and tie clips.
MARK MANDEL: I'm so in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're so
looking forward to that.
NEAL MUELLER: You'll see
them at the next Next.
MARK MANDEL: I am so in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's an amazing pun.
MARK MANDEL: I think
that's about it.
Is there anything else either
of you would like to add
or anything that hasn't been
mentioned that you think
is important?
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Thank you to you guys
for doing this podcast day
in day out, the tireless work
and creativity that you provide,
and thanks to our listeners
for being on Google
Cloud Platform, being
interested in what we're doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, you two,
for taking the time to
come and talk to us today.
MARK MANDEL: So Titan
is super, super cool.
Thanks to Cornelius and Neal
for coming by and giving us
a good long chat about that.
And thanks for
bringing one of them,
it was really cool
to play with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
got to touch one.
They're so cool!
MARK MANDEL: But why don't
we head on over and talk
to our dear friend Miles, whose
effervescent energy brings
everything to life.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Amazingly
excited and delighted to be
joined by Miles Ward,
Global Head of Solutions
at Google Cloud.
Thank you so much for
joining us, Miles.
MILES WARD: Thank you.
I'm just super
excited to be here.
What an incredible week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's an
amazing pleasure for me
to have you here.
I used to listen to your voice
a long time ago on that AWS
podcast, a long time ago.
MILES WARD: That's
exactly right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is amazing to have you
here at the GCP podcast now.
MILES WARD: It's just the
changing of the seasons.
We moved from the sort of
cold winter of one cloud
to the bright spring of another.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, I
like the metaphor.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Such a
beautiful and poetical way
of putting it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Before we talk to you
about Next and stuff,
can you tell us a bit about
what you do at Google?
MILES WARD: Absolutely.
So we have customers.
MARK MANDEL: Hopefully.
Hopefully.
The
MILES WARD: Lifeblood
of any cloud, right?
Cloud technology is
incredible stuff.
But it really
doesn't do anything
until it meets the road
with customer demand
and actual usage in the field.
So my team engages
with customers
as they've gone through
working with our sales
people, our customer
engineers, that
are kind of the first
line of technical defense,
and then they have
escalation points,
like folks that are in
specialist roles and in sales.
But when everybody gives
up, when everybody goes,
that's too technical and
scary and I'm not sure
how we would build that,
the Solutions Architecture
team is the top point
of escalation there.
So I run that team globally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
are also the team
that is responsible for all
the amazing white papers
that we have available, right?
MILES WARD: Yeah.
We think of it as a
very virtuous cycle.
We go out to customers that
all of our folks have told us,
we don't know how
to do this, and we
try to figure out how to do it.
If we're successful--
and we aren't always,
but most of the time we
are-- if we can figure out
how to make something
work, we write it down
because we are easily bored,
three or four times in a row.
So we write it
down, we publish it.
That's all the material that's
at cloud.google.com/solution.
And that stuff, our
best practices, or step
by step instructions on
how to move an application
to the cloud, or how to
back up an application,
or how to build it for
scale, or set up for IoT,
or do work in media and
entertainment, in oil and gas,
and all over the place.
So that kind of guidance,
one, gets us out
of doing the same thing twice.
But helps us stay focused on
what's next for customers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And also,
now that no one is listening,
helps us here at the
podcast, because we
might have been using
some of those solutions
as the main script for
our podcast episodes.
So thank you very
much for those ones.
MILES WARD: Hey, we
are here to help.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Then they show up and
we're like, oh, good.
Cool thing of the week, done.
MILES WARD: Well, it's
one of the things that's
exciting for me.
Any team has to grow.
You can't just install
a 200-person team out
of thin air.
We've been growing very rapidly.
And what it allows us to do
is ship more of this stuff.
We've gone from 12 of them
two years ago to 70% of them.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MILES WARD: I think we're going
to take a goal for 100 of them
getting shipped this year--
MARK MANDEL: That is crazy.
MILES WARD: --on top of that.
And we watch.
Like, I can see the statistics
of visitors coming in
and downloading this material.
And then I can see, they go
over and we see new accounts
that follow these patterns.
That's real business growing
on top of us and reduced risk.
I hate doing stuff
from scratch if I don't
know what it is that I'm doing.
When I'm not involved in some
kind of creative process,
if I'm just trying to get
something done and there
aren't instructions,
super of obnoxious.
So when we talk to customers,
every single one says, I just
want you to tell me how
I'm supposed to do it.
So we're trying to do that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
it's so much better
to learn from the
mistakes of others than--
MILES WARD: That's right.
MARK MANDEL: --doing yourself.
I think we have an environment
that really radically de-risks
that kind of
experimentation, I think
it's a fun place to build new
things and to try stuff out.
But I think some people have
a certain amount of budget
and a certain amount
of time and focus
for that kind of
experimentation,
and then the rest of the time
is spent on the obnoxious stuff
that should just work.
We're trying to go through
a step-by-step walk
through each of those pieces and
make it so that they just work.
Like, backing up
a database is not
something that is a creative
and advanced expression of--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I do that
on the weekend, so much fun.
MILES WARD: It should
probably have a manual.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Now, you obviously speak
to a lot of customers
and you've been
here at Cloud Next.
How have the experiences
for people you've
talked to have been like?
What has been the
response you've
had to the venue and event?
MILES WARD: I think
there's a couple of phrases
that have come out
of our keynotes
and come out of some of
our big presentations
that have had a really big
impact on the perspective
from the customers
that I talked with.
I went to three different
customer dinners
just last night.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Did you
eat dinner three times?
MILES WARD: Well, you know,
you can have a lot of salad
and everybody sort of thinks
that you're participating
in the fullness of the chow.
So what I heard from customers
was three basic things.
First was from
the first keynote,
seeing HSBC on stage,
that's an account that I
did a lot of work
with, I was super
excited to see them
take the stage.
Seeing how clearly for
them the value of cloud
was associated with the
speed with which they could
do things, like
what they're seeing
in every one of the
examples and demonstrations.
And this stuff is fast.
It's not fast like 100 million
IOPS or something like that.
It's fast like it takes
Evernote three months
to move, it takes
Lush a month to move,
it takes Ocado six hours
to rewrite their ETL.
These statistics are now the
material to go, wait a minute,
I'm planning and
budgeting in the back
of my mind on like
Netflix scales,
where it's going to take
seven years to migrate.
If I can do this stuff in
months instead of years,
the economics are
totally different,
the value proposition
is totally different.
If I go around
enterprise to enterprise,
even little startups
that are already
implemented in
other places, they
say, wow, I didn't realize
that it was that much faster.
That's a big deal to me, that
really changes my perspective.
So that's awesome.
That's super awesome to see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's something
to be said there about
also the exponential growth
that you can have.
like PokemonGo, Niantic.
MILES WARD: Yeah.
To talk about
exponential growth,
I was at the GCP event-- they
didn't call it Next yet--
three years ago.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
I remember those.
MILES WARD: 375 people there.
I went to the one
last year, presented
a bunch, built a bunch
of stuff there, built
the tree house over there
for that [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
MILES WARD: There
were 2,600 people that
came through the door for that.
There are like almost
14,000 people here.
MARK MANDEL: It's crazy.
MILES WARD: It's 10x and
then 5x to say, OK, fine, 3x.
We're going to have to put
in intermediary floors inside
of Moscone to fit enough
humans to watch all the stuff
that we're building up.
That's outrageous growth.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
amazing also seeing
all the number of other partners
that we have all around.
It is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Even just walking
through the startup space,
there's like 10, 15
of them in there,
just all of them doing each
individual cool things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
other things have you
heard from customers that
they're really excited about?
Was there any specific
announcement or something
like that that they were like,
oh, that thing was amazing?
MILES WARD: I was surprised--
I know the degree
to which we hold it
as sort of its own
unique class of things.
But the messaging around
Spanner has landed.
And when I talk
to customers, they
go, look, man, I read
that paper five years ago.
I know that you guys had the
crown jewels hiding someplace.
I know that that's the one.
We are diving in,
figuring it out.
And I'm watching on the inside
as we work with customers,
and look at the metrics.
The growth on Spanner adoption
in weeks is stupefying.
I've got engineers on the
SRE team changing trajectory
of focus to deploy more
and more infrastructure
into the Spanner
hosting just to be
able to keep pace with demand.
And as our customers
are talking about it,
I think they got the message up
front about the idea of, yeah,
I can do globally
consistent transactions.
I can make it so that
when I write something
on one side of the planet, on
the other side of the planet
I'm not messed up
and out of sync.
But I don't think
they really realized
that that came along with super,
super fast, super, super big.
Like, the simpler message of,
yep, millions of IOPS is OK,
yup, doing it at
gazillions of bytes
you can put terabytes in there,
is fine, petabytes in there,
is whatever.
So like, I get both?
Wait a minute, how--
why-- how am I-- what?
It seems very
surprising to them.
So it's cool that we've
then able to really hammer
on both of those messages and
I'm seeing businesses saying,
it's weird, you're right,
I don't like my Oracle
and I'm not super stoked about
my mySQL, and all of those
are sort of a pain in the neck.
Like, maybe I
should try this out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what's
your point of view on the fact
that Spanner is still beta?
Does that mean that
people are not using it?
It seems like it's
the other way around.
MILES WARD: No.
In my experience, what I've
seen-- you have to imagine,
there's a range of products that
are being built by Google Cloud
Platform, that are being built
for cloud right now as we
speak, built from scratch.
The GLP API is not that way.
We take a service from G
Suite and we externalize it
as a dedicated service
that customers can use.
Spanner is an
example that's more
that way, where we have
a running production
system handling millions
and millions of transactions
a second, serving hundreds
of Google businesses.
It is highly mature in
its operations model,
our SLOs are well defined, we
have a clear standard service
there.
The new part is that
we're charging for it.
There's this little
billing component
that's got to get
slapped on, you
got to have an API
that's externalized
that you have to slap on.
And we need to test those
to the same level of rigor
as the core operations.
I think in the
database world, for me
the big risk or the big terror
is losing data or having
data corrupted.
And I think those are the
places where the new layers that
are part of Spanner to
make it so that they
can be a public
service, they just
don't affect that part at all.
So I see customers able to
do that calculus and say,
yeah, let's dive in,
let's figure that out.
MARK MANDEL: Since you're
on the customer side,
now I'm just curious.
Are you seeing customers--
are they jumping on the beta?
Being able to kind of provide
feedback and push the direction
of where the product goes?
MILES WARD: Yeah.
I had a great
conversation on Twitter
yesterday that one of the parts
of the design of the product,
in order to be able to meet the
tight SLOs that it's designed
for, to be able to
deliver the kind
of transactional consistency,
it's not multitenant.
So we ask you to build
individual nodes,
which we call on
our side, and like
any good relational
structure that's replicated,
your real default there
is to deploy three nodes.
So the minimum cost to run
it 24/7 with those three base
nodes putting lots of
gigabytes of data in there,
it's about 2,000 bucks a month.
So when I talk to
developers, they
say, look, when I'm in prod,
I'm going to give you $200,000
a month because I'm
going to want this
at the size of the moon.
But right now I want to
mess around on my laptop
and I want to mess
around in a way
that I know is compatible
with the primary thing.
Or, fine, if it's impossible
to put on my laptop,
give me something that I can
run on a micro, or whatever,
so that it's at a price
when it's compatible.
And I know our
product managers, they
made an analysis of
the market and they're
looking at what technology
they have available.
I think we were
really eager to take
what we know of as the exact
best practice for a product
that already has a reputation
years before it's launched
and make sure that that
product behaves exactly the way
customers have dreamed
about for years.
Now they've got their
hands on the real deal.
The feedback that I've
heard is clear enough
that it's obvious to me
that we'll go through and do
the work to create something
that's designed for developer
consumption so that the
experimentation can happen
without costing a couple grand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is
there anything else
that you think our audience
would like to know?
Like any anecdote, anything
that might have happened
backstage that
you'd like to share?
MILES WARD: Sure.
I'll tell you one that's funny.
So Chris [INAUDIBLE], who's
the product manager building
all the stuff for Windows.
He's the guy who did
the car crash onstage
with the Hot Wheels.
That I think it's hysterical.
Like, we need to do that
sort of at a different scale
and we bring it up, he
actually makes the crash noise
and everything.
So what he told me was that
you really had to go through it
and think hard about
which Hot Wheels would
you bring on stage.
Like, these are going to
be famous Hot Wheel cars.
They're going to
take some videos.
It's like he sort of had to
pick through his kid's box
and find just the two
coolest trucks that he had.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
that we have amazing speakers
and they do the weirdest things.
We also saw this morning,
Justin Beckwith with a durian.
MILES WARD: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, taking
it [INAUDIBLE], just cause.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't
know what happened there
but that is pretty amazing.
MILES WARD: Unbelievable.
MARK MANDEL: All right, Miles.
Well, thanks for taking
the time to come hang out
with us at the
podcast, we really
appreciate you telling
all the stories.
And, hey, man, if you ever
want to come back again,
we'd be more than
happy to have you.
MILES WARD: Hey, you guys are
doing outrageously great work.
I work every day and take
benefit from the awareness
that you create, so
I super appreciate it
and I'd love to come back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In
exchange, next time
you come you need
to play the tuba.
MILES WARD: I will [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: You have a tuba?
Oh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
There's a backstory there.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you so much.
MILES WARD: Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Bye.
MARK MANDEL: So
thanks again, Miles,
for such an interesting
conversation.
I've met him long time ago.
First time I heard his
name was long time ago
on the AWS podcast.
Last time I saw him
was somewhere in Japan,
he was giving talks
around the world.
He's a super cool guy.
So thanks so much for taking
the time to talk to us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is sad, but--
MARK MANDEL: It's over.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--this is the end.
MARK MANDEL: This is the end.
Well, at least till next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, till next week.
This is the end of
Cloud Next 2017.
It was an amazing conference.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And we didn't want
to finish the episode, the
fourth episode in this week,
without saying I huge
thanks to our dear editors.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Sean, James, thank you
so much for putting up
with this during daily episodes,
editing all that podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
To everyone who's listening,
huge thanks to them
because they do an
amazing, amazing job.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, especially
because maybe you can not tell,
but we're incredibly tired so we
actually keep on messing it up
and they need to edit it
out, back to making it
sound almost normal.
So, thank you, again.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
And Francesc, thank you to you
for being so wonderful here as
well today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark,
for being here on your birthday.
Happy birthday.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
And thanks to everyone
who came past the booth,
said hello, grabbed
some stickers,
grabbed some t-shirts,
even just wandered up
and we were just like
hey, we love the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was awesome.
Thank you all so, so much.
We really felt the love.
MARK MANDEL: And thanks
to everyone who listened.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And talk
to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.